Who do you think of when you hear the words
“father of the atomic bomb”?
We’re guessing it’s Robert Oppenheimer,
the leader of the Manhattan Project who famously
responded to the first A-Bomb test by declaring
“now I am become Death, destroyer of worlds.”
But what if we told you there was another
contender?
A scientist who came this close to making
the big breakthrough in 1934… a breakthrough
that could have resulted in Nazi Germany developing
the world’s first nuclear weapon.
The scientist who almost created this terrifying
alternative reality was Enrico Fermi, the
godfather of the atom bomb.
A leading light in both experimental and theoretical
physics, Fermi was an almost once-in-a-generation
genius.
It was Fermi who built the first operational
nuclear reactor in 1942, Fermi who created
our understanding of the subatomic particles
known today as fermions, and Fermi who helped
Oppenheimer father the Bomb.
From fascist Italy to WWII America, this is
the life of Enrico Fermi, the greatest Italian
scientist this side of Galileo.
The Quiet Italian
One of themes we’ve touched on, time and
again is that - despite what fiction tells
you - you usually can’t tell which child
is gonna grow up to change the world.
Otto von Bismarck, for example, was lazy as
a kid.
Mathematician Emmy Noether was going to be
a language teacher.
Johannes Kepler was obsessed with joining
the priesthood.
But there are times when even real life follows
the rules of fiction.
Times when you really can just look at a child
and think “that kid’s gonna be world-famous
one day.”
Enrico Fermi was one of those kids.
Born in Rome on September 29, 1901, Fermi
came from an average family.
His father was a government railway inspector,
while his mother Ida was a teacher.
But Ida was above average in one very particular
way.
She believed acquiring knowledge was almost
a sacred duty.
You might say this was the closest thing to
a religion in the Fermi household.
Unusually for the time, the family weren’t
Catholic, and sent young Fermi to one of the
few secular schools in Rome.
There, aged only six, Enrico Fermi began to
show signs of the genius he would become.
Basically, from the moment he started school,
Fermi was consistently at the top of his class.
Ida had instilled in him a deep love for math,
science, engineering, and everything else
brainy.
When not studying, the boy spent his time
building electric motors with his older brother
Giulio.
So, yeah, if you’d been introduced to child
Fermi circa 1910, you’d have probably thought
to yourself “that kid’s gonna be big.”
But you might not have guessed he’d be big
in the world of physics.
That’s because it’d take a tragedy to
set Fermi on that particular path.
In January, 1915, Fermi’s brother Giulio
went into hospital for routine surgery on
a throat abscess.
Something went wrong, and he died on the operating
table, bleeding out aged only 15.
For the teenage Fermi, this was like God had
just cruelly hurled a lightning bolt right
into the middle of his life.
As a boy, Fermi had always been shy and introverted.
But in the wake of Giulio’s death, he became
almost catatonically withdrawn.
Frightened, Ida tried to convince her son
to lose himself in his studies.
She found a fifty year old book on physics,
and gave it to the boy to read.
What Fermi read there blew his young mind.
There was something about the world described
in that book that just made sense to Fermi,
that made him want to learn more.
From that point on, the boy wouldn’t be
a magpie, leaping from one STEM subject to
the next.
His mind would instead be a high-powered laser,
focused solely on physics.
In 1918, three years after Giulio died, Fermi
applied to the prestigious Scuola Normale
Superiore in Pisa.
On November 14 that year he sat the entrance
exam.
The task was to write a competitive essay.
Fermi chose the topic Characteristics of Sound.
When the examiner read it, he nearly fell
off his chair.
While anyone sitting this exam was naturally
intelligent, Fermi was at a whole other level.
He’d turned in a paper that would’ve been
impressive for a doctoral thesis.
Fermi was instantly fast-tracked onto the
school’s doctoral program, with his advisor
the director of the physics laboratory.
But the director soon realized this kid was
such a natural that it was impossible to teach
him stuff.
In just three years of self-study, Fermi had
become so good at physics that he could run
rings around a department chair.
Everybody at the school could agree on one
thing.
They couldn’t wait to see what he did next.
Breaking Italy
At the same time Fermi was rising through
the physics profession like an out of control
weather balloon, another Italian also found
himself being catapulted toward stardom.
On March 23, 1919 - mere months after Fermi
sat his exam - Benito Mussolini founded the
Fascist Party.
Although neither Fermi nor Mussolini could’ve
known it at the time, their lives were destined
to cross in a way that would change history.
Within a year of the Fascist Party’s appearance,
chapters had sprung up across the nation,
and whole regions descended into violence.
Mussolini was a world class rabble rouser,
a guy who could whip up a mob in the time
it takes to boil an egg.
As his influence spread, blackshirt militias
began attacking leftists, burning down trade
union offices, and physically stopping leftwing
officials from taking their posts.
Come July, 1922, the whole of Italy knew Mussolini’s
name, and either loved or loathed him.
With possibly one exception.
All his life, Enrico Fermi would be staunchly
apolitical, never showing the slightest hint
of interest in politics.
As Italy fell into chaos that summer, he was
likely thinking of one thing only: defending
his thesis.
By now, Fermi had already published his first
couple of papers, and his planet-sized brain
was infamous across Pisa.
When he actually came to defend his thesis
before 11 examiners, it’s said only two
of them were capable of grasping what he was
talking about.
Fermi graduated with honors, almost immediately
receiving a government grant to continue his
studies.
Not that that government would be around much
longer.
That same summer, Mussolini’s blackshirts
smashed a general strike called by Italian
leftists.
On 24 October, before a gathering of 40,000
fascists, Il Duce declared that the government
was incapable of governing, and that his party
would physically remove it from power.
Mussolini’s March on Rome was the moment
democracy died in Italy.
Faced with an insurrection, the government
collapsed.
Preferring fascism to anarchy, King Victor
Emmanuel III invited Mussolini to form a new
government.
On Halloween that year - a fitting date if
there ever was one - Italy’s balder, fatter
version of Hitler became Prime Minister, the
first fascist leader in history.
But while life was about to take a bad turn
for Italy in general, it was taking a series
of extremely good turns for Enrico Fermi.
Between 1922 and 1926, Fermi won a series
of scholarships, going abroad to teach in
Germany and the Netherlands.
By the time he settled back in Italy in 1926,
he was ready to change the world.
Offered the chair of theoretical physics at
the University of Rome, aged just 25, Fermi
made breakthrough after breakthrough.
Perhaps his most lasting was the development
of what are known as Fermi-Dirac statistics
- basically a way of understanding a group
of subatomic particles that would otherwise
make us go “whaaaaaaaaa-?”
every time we thought about them.
In fact, Fermi was so prolific, and his intuition
so often accurate, that his colleagues started
calling him “the Pope” of physics.
But it wasn’t just Fermi’s colleagues
who were paying attention to his extraordinary
mind.
In 1929, Benito Mussolini - now absolute dictator
of Italy - personally appointed Fermi to the
Accademia dei Lincei.
The apolitical physicist was given a huge
salary, a uniform to wear, and the title of
“excellency.”
All he had to do in return was bring glory
upon Mussolini’s Italy by making more breakthroughs.
Scarily, that’s exactly what happened.
In his new post, Fermi would soon come terrifyingly
close to giving Il Duce the key to the atom
bomb.
Fathering the Bomb
The next few years were crazy-busy for Fermi.
In 1928, he married Laura Capon, daughter
of a respected Jewish family, with whom he’d
have two children.
In 1930, he made his first visit to America,
where he lectured on quantum theory.
Shortly after, Fermi seems to have decided
the quantum field was becoming exhausted.
He switched his focus to nuclear physics.
It was this switch that would lead to his
big breakthrough.
In 1934, Fermi and his team were researching
the atom.
They’d already discovered that pretty much
every element is capable of nuclear transformation,
and were now focusing on uranium.
It was while working with the element that
Fermi discovered the first step toward nuclear
fission.
Since we’re a history channel rather than
a science channel, we’re not qualified to
go deep into this.
But the basic gist is that Fermi made a breakthrough,
from which any garden-variety genius could’ve
deduced other breakthroughs could be made,
eventually leading to everything from nuclear
reactors to A-Bombs.
As the 2016 book The Pope of Physics notes,
had Fermi’s brain been firing on all cylinders
at that time, it’s likely nuclear fission
would’ve been discovered in Italy in 1935.
One possible consequence?
Nazi Germany using that research to acquire
nuclear weapons.
It’s a scary thought that out there, just
a few degrees away, sits a parallel universe
where the London Blitz was not a sustained
campaign, but a single bomb, falling from
the sky, that turned the British capital into
rubble in a flash of light.
Luckily, we don’t live in that universe.
In our universe, Fermi’s brain - for some
reason - wasn’t quite operating at full
capacity.
He merely thought he’d created a new element;
one the press argued should be named after
Mussolini.
By the time everyone figured out what was
actually going on, any headstart Nazi Germany
could’ve got on the Bomb was gone.
In terms of near misses, they don’t get
much nearer than that.
Still, Fermi’s work was important, important
enough for him to be awarded the Nobel Prize
for Physics in 1938.
And that’s today’s second stroke of good
luck, because 1938 was when everything went
to hell.
That summer, Mussolini suddenly brought in
a raft of anti-Jewish laws.
So extreme were these laws, so nakedly modeled
on Hitler’s, that they penetrated even Fermi’s
physics-addled mind.
Although he was staunchly apolitical, Fermi
couldn’t ignore the fact that these new
laws targeted his wife; and probably their
children.
Unfortunately, the new laws also made it impossible
for Jews to leave Italy without a very good
reason.
A reason like, oh, I dunno… winning the
Nobel Prize?
That December, Fermi traveled to Sweden to
collect his Nobel Prize for Physics.
He took his family with him, the no-travel
laws for Jews briefly waived on the understanding
that the award would bring glory on Italy.
In Stockholm, Fermi accepted his award, then
used his prize money to get himself, his wife,
and his children on a boat to the USA.
And that’s how Italy’s greatest modern
scientist came to leave his country behind
for good.
It’s curious to think that, had Mussolini
not suddenly passed those anti-Jewish laws,
Fermi would’ve likely stayed in Italy for
the duration of the war.
All the work he’d do under Oppenheimer would
be lost.
Lost, too, would be the world’s first nuclear
reactor, soon to be built under Fermi’s
watch in Chicago.
And Fermi was just one of thousands of scientists
who fled the continent in those days.
Had Europe’s fascists not become so obsessed
with national purity, their nations would
ironically have lasted so much longer.
On January 2, 1939, the Fermis arrived in
New York City.
For the rest of their lives, the Fermis would
call America “home”.
“A labor of considerable scientific interest”
Barely had Fermi set foot inside Columbia
than he was already gifting his new government
breakthroughs.
That same spring, 1939, the Italian and his
team showed that emitting neutrons into uranium
that was in the process of fissioning could
trigger a chain reaction.
In other words: KA-BOOM.
By March, the university was already writing
to the Navy, suggesting that this could be
used as a weapon.
Nor was Fermi himself blind to this possibility.
One day in a Manhattan highrise, he glanced
out a window at the bustling city and murmured
“a little bomb like that and it would all
disappear.”
But Fermi was no Oppenheimer, tortured inside
by the destruction his research could wreak.
He actually went to Washington, DC personally
to try and drum up funding for nuclear weapons
research.
But his presentation was so singularly uncharismatic
that he walked away with only the smallest
of grants.
It wasn’t until Albert Einstein personally
wrote to Franklin D Roosevelt about the potential
for superweapons that the American government
began to really show interest.
Still, it was a slow process.
Only on December 6, 1941 was a project to
study these theories in Chicago signed off
on.
But if things had been moving slowly for Fermi’s
research up until that point, they were about
to gain a sense of extreme urgency.
So, you remember history class.
You know what happened on December 7, 1941.
The Japanese bombing of Pearl Harbor dragged
America kicking and screaming into the war.
It also had the side effect that every Italian
in the country was immediately classed an
“enemy alien,” and subjected to severe
travel restrictions.
It took nearly six months for Fermi’s restrictions
to be waived for his research.
He finally arrived in Chicago in summer, 1942.
But once he was there, Fermi almost immediately
proved his worth.
We already spoke one terrifying parallel universe
earlier, where the Axis got the Bomb.
Now we’re going to speak about a much weirder
one.
The universe where this video isn’t titled
“Enrico Fermi: Godfather of the Atomic Bomb”,
but “Enrico Fermi: the Mad Scientist who
Destroyed Chicago.”
Fermi and his team assembled a nuclear reactor
on the squash court of the University of Chicago
toward the end of 1942.
On December 2, they sent it critical.
As the New York Times later wrote of the potentially-dangerous
experiment:
“The only safeguards against an uncontrolled
atomic chain reaction that would have irradiated
a significant part of Chicago was a scientist
wielding an ax to cut the rope that held an
emergency control rod suspended from the balcony,
and a few other brave volunteers, whose job
was to douse the runaway reactor with buckets
of neutron-absorbing cadmium sulfate.”
Fermi actually joked that, if the reactor
went out of control, the assembled team should
run and hide behind a big hill many miles
away.
But, of course, Chicago Pile-1 didn’t become
Chernobyl before Chernobyl.
It worked, creating a self-sustaining atomic
chain reaction - the first working nuclear
reactor in history.
Shortly after, a code was broadcast to Washington,
DC: “The Italian navigator has just landed
in the new world”.
It was the dawn of the atomic age.
It was also the dawn of a new age in Fermi’s
work.
In 1944, the Italian physicist became a naturalized
US citizen.
Shortly after, he was sent down to Los Alamos
to work on the Manhattan Project under Robert
Oppenheimer.
Fermi was actually there on July 16, 1945,
when the first Plutonium bomb was tested,
at the infamous Trinity test in Alamogordo,
New Mexico.
This was the moment when Oppenheimer, seeing
the power he had unleashed, thought the phrase
“I am become death, destroyer of worlds.”
But - as we’ve said before - Fermi was no
Oppenhemier.
Faced with the reality of a weapon capable
of wiping out entire cities in the blink of
an eye, Fermi only noted that the Trinity
test was “a labor of considerable scientific
interest.”
How I Learned to Stop Worrying...
In the last months of the Manhattan Project,
Fermi’s dedication to building the Bomb
didn’t waver.
Although in April, he noted that their labors
would one day be able to be reproduced by
“smaller nations or even groups,” he still
thought it a worthwhile endeavour.
That June, he joined the Scientific Panel
of the Interim Committee, a group tasked - in
part - with advising on the use of atomic
weapons against Japan.
Just like his colleagues, Fermi advocated
for an atomic strike.
Although some members of the panel did object
on ethical grounds, preferring instead a public
test that would give Japan warning, President
Harry Truman signed off on an attack.
Just two months later, on August 6, 1945,
a bomb distilled from the work of Fermi, Oppenheimer,
and the other geniuses at Los Alamos was loaded
onto the Enola Gay and flown off into the
night sky.
Six hours later, the Enola Gay’s bomb bay
doors opened above the commercial and military
city of Hiroshima.
Little Boy dropped for 44 seconds.
At the end of that time, the world changed
forever.
The first atomic bomb ever used in warfare
detonated at precisely 08:16:02 am some 609
meters above Hiroshima.
Within 0.1 of a second, the air over the city
center had reached 277,760 C. A woman sat
nearly a kilometer away on the banks of the
city’s river was instantly vaporized.
As the fireball expanded, granite stones melted,
the internal organs of humans and animals
vaporized, and exposed skin was burned off.
By the time a single second had passed, a
blast wave traveling at 1,500 km/h had torn
the clothes off nearly everyone in the city,
destroyed 60,000 buildings; and an intense
firestorm had started that would rage for
hours and hours.
In that instant, 80,000 people died, including
up to 20,000 Korean slave laborers and over
a dozen Allied POWs.
Many tens of thousands more would die of radiation
poisoning over the coming weeks.
It was carnage on a previously unimaginable
scale.
And it wasn’t over.
Three days later, on August 9, another plane
carrying another bomb flew over Japan.
Originally, it was meant to drop its payload
on the ancient city of Kokura, but thick cloud
cover meant that Nagasaki became its target.
At 11:02am, Fat Man exploded above the port
city, turning over 40,000 people into ash.
It was the second, and - to date - last time
atomic weapons were used in warfare.
Six days later, Japan surrendered unconditionally.
Today, it remains up for debate whether the
real motivation for Japanese surrender was
the two atomic bombs, or the USSR’s declaration
of war the same day as Nagasaki.
Whatever the truth, there’s no denying that
the weapons Fermi helped build had just shocked
the world.
By now, though, the war was already over in
Europe.
In Italy, partisans had captured Mussolini
back in April, stringing up his corpse in
a Milan square.
Hitler, too, was dead - killed by a self-inflicted
gunshot in his Fhurerbunker.
The fascists who’d chased Fermi and his
family out of Europe were gone.
The physicist could now go back to his home
country whenever he chose.
But what remained in Italy for him?
His wife’s family were dead, killed in the
Holocaust.
Rome lay in ruins.
Instead, in fall of 1945, Fermi accepted a
teaching position at the University of Chicago.
He would live in the city for the rest of
his life.
The Last Paradox
The last years of Enrico Fermi’s life were
marked by a return to the magpie-like fascination
that characterized his earlier years.
At Chicago, he moved on from nuclear physics
and began researching elementary particles,
before becoming obsessed with cosmic rays.
Perhaps his most-famous contribution to science
in this time, though, came not in the form
of a discovery, but of a question.
“Where is everybody?”
In 1950, Fermi was lunching with some colleagues
when they began to discuss alien civilizations.
This was three years after the supposed Roswell
Crash, a time when UFOs were all the rage.
One by one, Fermi’s friends asserted that
there were undoubtedly aliens out there in
the galaxy.
It was at this point that Fermi asked his
question.
“Where is everybody?” may sound like a
flip remark, but Fermi had a serious point.
He’d realized that - given the immense age
of the galaxy - any civilization with even
the most rudimentary rocket technology should’ve
colonized it by now.
Assuming even a hyper-conservative estimate
for how often an intelligent civilization
arises, the sheer time scales involved meant
there should be abundant evidence of aliens
by now.
So, again.
Where is everyone?
Today, that simple question is known as the
Fermi Paradox, and the list of explanations
as to why there are no signs of alien life
could fill a dozen videos all by themselves.
Seriously, if you want to head down an infinite
click-hole, just type “the great filter”
or “dark forest theory” into Google.
But while Fermi may have meddled in many disciplines
in his later years, he could never quite escape
the one thread running throughout his working
life: nuclear physics.
In 1949, Fermi joined the General Advisory
Committee to the Atomic Energy Commission.
That year, the USSR had tested its first atomic
weapon, and the Committee had gathered to
decide on the practical and moral implications
of the USA developing thermonuclear devices.
Unlike the atomic bombing of Japan, Fermi
was steadfastly against the idea.
A hydrogen bomb, he wrote in an dissension
from the majority opinion, “becomes a weapon
which in practical effect is almost one of
genocide….
It is necessarily an evil thing considered
in any light.”
After a lifetime with no political opinions
at all, it seemed Enrico Fermi was finally
waking up to a world where governments might
use his discoveries for evil.
But this new mindset only went so far.
When Truman signed off on the H-Bomb, Fermi
dutifully went back to Los Alamos to work
on it.
It’s said he hoped to prove such a weapon
was impossible.
If that’s the case, he was doomed to disappointment.
The world’s first hydrogen bomb was tested
in the Marshall Islands on November 1, 1952.
The explosion was so vast, so world-changing
in its implications, that it graced the cover
of Time.
Not long after, Fermi came up with his own,
pessimistic answer for the Fermi Paradox.
There were no alien civilizations because
they’d all wiped themselves out with thermonuclear
weapons.
Still, Fermi being Fermi, he carried on working.
There were doubtless more discoveries to be
made.
In the summer of 1954, he even went back to
Italy, hiking in the mountains and enjoying
the air of the old country.
At least, that was the plan.
The reality was Fermi found himself feeling
constantly run down.
When he returned to Chicago at the end of
his vacation, he went straight to the doctor.
Since you can already see we’re nearing
the end of the video, you can probably guess
what came next.
The doctors told Fermi he had stomach cancer.
Although they tried to cure it, the disease
was already too far advanced.
Enrico Fermi died on November 28, 1954.
He was 53.
Today, Fermi’s name lives on - most notably
in the Paradox named after him, and the element
fermium, discovered in 1953.
While it’s doubtful the average Joe has
heard of him, he remains highly-respected,
a genius who still gets his due.
Yet its interesting to recall just how unlikely
this great reputation was.
If things had been just a shade different,
Fermi could’ve gone down in history as the
man who accidentally gave the Axis the Bomb.
Or he could’ve become trapped in Italy in
1938, and perished alongside his wife in the
Holocaust.
He may even have made it to America, only
to send Chicago Pile-1 out of control and
cause the world’s first nuclear meltdown.
Thankfully, this universe is one where disaster
never struck; where Fermi’s genius helped
shape the world rather than end it.
He may have lived a relatively short life,
but Fermi did enough work in his five decades
to fill hundreds of lifetimes.